[Music]
let's go to joe in waycross georgia
what's up joe
hey what's up dr john we're rocking up
man what are you doing
oh just trying to get better day by day
how we're here that's exactly exactly
the same
exactly the same so what's up man
um just had a question i've been
listening to you for a couple months now
and
one of the things you say all the time
started uh brought up a question with me
i wanted to ask
you um
uh you said all the time uh one of the
keys to being well uh owning and
acknowledging reality
yes and
as someone that struggled with mental
health issues most of my adult life
um
i have a hard time
being sure what reality actually is
sometimes yes sir
um
how can we be sure of that because i'm
always being told like i'll set
boundaries with people and relationships
and then when i start feeling those
boundaries are being squashed i'm always
being told
i'm wrong
who's telling you who's telling you that
joe
uh just you know everybody it's like you
set boundaries and
and this is you're always the problem
you're always fault um give me an
example
um
uh
uh well uh ex-wife that i just got
divorced from uh girlfriends uh parents
but give me an example of a boundary you
set then somebody
says you're that you're the dummy for
having a boundary
like well since i've been divorced and
started trying to date again you know
i'll
i'll say from the beginning whenever i
start seeing somebody these are certain
things i don't i don't want to
do
like there are certain
aspects that are expected in a
relationship you know it seems like
people only want
you for certain things
um
okay so let me put let me throw
something out there
let's say
you're dating
and you say hey i don't pay for anybody
else's food
i just paid for mine
and also i'm not interested in a sexual
relationship i just want to date and
have fun
and by the way i only watch horror
movies that's it i only watch crazy
slasher films
in and of themselves
all three of those boundaries
they're not crazy or wrong or whatever
they're yours
and somebody can opt into a relationship
with you
or
they can opt out of a relationship with
you
it's when you decide that your the
relationship the allure of being with
somebody is more important than what
your body's telling you is important
um becomes a problem or when it violates
your values right
right did any of those ring a bell
well yes because that's what i'm that's
kind of what i was getting at because
it's like people
i feel like people only want
to be around me for what i can provide
to them not for me is who i am and
whenever i call them out on that i'm
made to feel like a bad person okay
because it's like okay when i'll start
seeing somebody it's like okay i want to
spend time together get to know you but
then it's like okay
um well you know hey
since you're here you know
you know why don't you cut my grass or
why don't you
you're handy why don't you why don't you
build me these shelves or it's like hold
on you know i know somebody can come
over and do plumbing work if you want
you know because i've had many different
jobs in my life
i came to spend time with you not to be
your employee and that was all right
that was how my ex made me feel okay
which is you know and
i don't want to do that again so when i
start feeling used that's one of the
one of your callers made me
realize that one of my diet previous
diagnosis might have been one of my
problems
and i'm burning bridges too fast
have you have you felt have you been
used your whole life
i feel that way yeah
but then i started questioning if i was
just burning bridges too fast because
um here's two important things okay are
three important things
number one
if you and i spent a significant amount
of time together you could probably tell
me some pretty wild stories from when
you were younger is that fair
yes okay you probably went you've
probably seen and went through a lot as
a kid is that fair
yes okay
often
those things that our bodies had to do
to keep us alive
when we were kids
like
i'm gonna do all the chores around here
so the dad won't hit me anymore
i'm gonna make sure this house is
spotless so that mom won't fly off the
handle and smash the cabinets
i'm going to maybe if i
fill in the blank if i disappear they
won't hit me or abuse me if i get
between mom and dad he'll hit me instead
of her like we have all of these
behaviors that we had that show up when
we're kids in their survival
and then those exact same things our
bodies remember those relationally and
they show up and we're adults
and they're
the nerd word is maladaptive they screw
up our adult relationships because
we're not trying to survive anymore
in it all it means is our alarm system
is pretty highly attuned
and it's it's what was once keeping us
safe a uh
a
alarm that detects smoke is really
important in a kitchen or in a house
it's not very helpful over a campfire
all right
same alarm is detecting the same set of
chemicals and in one place it's really
important one place it's ruining
everybody's good time because we just
want to have s'mores right so here's you
asked a brilliant question joe a really
important question
and
you and i have different diagnosis
probably but i've had my own mental
health challenges my whole life okay
especially into adulthood
here's the um two important things
that um
guide me moving forward okay
number one
is i get other people particularly in my
case and in your case other men
that we do not have
other people in our lives that are not
romantic relationships but they are
accountability and trust relationships
okay
what that looks like is this
if my wife says something or does
something over a period of a couple of
days
and i get to a point where i'm raged out
my body is acting in a bonkers way
because i know my wife loves me and i
know she wouldn't like try to hurt me
but i just get angry i have a couple of
men in my life that i'll call and i'll
walk through the situation and they'll
say dalona you're acting crazy
and
because i know that my feelings can be a
lot sometimes and my emotions can be a
lot i know that i don't always trust
them and so i've got a couple of guys
that i do trust that if they tell me hey
you go apologize to your wife until
you're sorry
i'll go do that because they're right
see what i'm saying so i have a group of
men in my life that i outsource that i
trust
the other thing in my life
is that i have a very clear sense of
what i call the objective data okay
i don't always feel like exercising i
don't always feel like saying i'm sorry
i don't always feel like writing a thank
you note i don't always feel like
going to bed
but i know those things help keep me
well
and so i know the data is more important
than how i feel most of the time
does that make sense
yes so i've got some objective data in
my life that i am pretty tied in with
okay whether that's meeting with a
doctor which i which i have or whether
that's coming up with objective you know
my heart rate variability and i know
when i need to sleep versus wanting to
go exercise and things like that
i know i need to eat healthy most of the
time because if i don't then it starts
me on a path and then i end up being a
being bonkers down the road right
but
all this to say is i know
that my feelings and emotions aren't
always they tell me a lot but they don't
always tell me the truth
okay and so i'm gonna find people that i
trust and i'm gonna find data that i
trust
and i'm gonna let those guide me when
i'm struggling now here's the big number
three
the goal for all of us whether we
struggle with mental health or not
is to learn to trust our bodies
okay
and if somebody asks you to do something
and it makes you feel less than or
uncomfortable or like you're being used
trust your body joe okay
enjoy
until you have a close friend that's a
mentor and you tell him and he says dude
just help out
but if you feel like you're dating
somebody and they're treating you like a
like a handyman
go with your gut on that one okay
okay is that fair oh yeah i mean that
was just a example okay yeah no i know i
know
but
um
that's how i navigate and that's how i
tell other people to navigate one of the
wild things about psychiatry and mental
health challenges is
at the root of your question which is
there is no objective blood test for
depression or anxiety there's no blood
test for obsessive-compulsive disorder
right
so you have to take somebody who's
struggling
with their thoughts and their feelings
and emotions and communicate them in a
way to a doctor
that they can take a very imperfect tool
with imperfect feelings and senses and
data and try to give you a perfect
diagnosis that's why i have a lot of
struggles with a lot of diagnosis that
people get
um
but yes the whole idea of it it's tough
right so
get some people that you trust get some
data that you trust in your life i feel
good when i'm at this weight i feel good
when i exercise i feel good when i've
slept this many hours
um
oh i feel even better when i sleep this
many hours because i've got a continuous
glucose monitor now that monitors what i
eat and i've got a whoop strap or
whatever that or the honu strap that
monitors my heart rate variability right
all these things that you can
get in your life that you can trust so
some of the times i think i just need to
sleep in i need to sleep in i can look
at my heart rate variability like nope i
need to go run
great man because i know enough to know
about myself that i don't always trust
my feelings i always trust my emotions
so i hope that helps answer your
question joe it's a great great question
and i'm really grateful that you reached
out and asked
um get some people man
and get the right numbers around you and
then
trust that body